So in high school,
I have these two friends named Dan and Joe.
That's what we're gonna call them for now.
We were going into English class, and they sat together.
And I sat in the corner of the classroom by myself.
The English teacher was speaking,
and I could see at the corner of my eye
that they are rough housing with each other,
like the dudes that they are.
At first I looked at them and I was like, yeah,
they're just dudes.
Like, they do this all the time.
But the midway,
as the fucking English teacher was speaking,
all I hear is,
when I tell you,
everyone's head, like,
turn to them.
All I see is Joe, like,
his head was down,
he was laughing.
And all Joe says is, miss,
I swear it wasn't me, it was him.
I don't know why he did that noise.
And all Dan said was, nothing.
Absolutely fucking nothing.
This fool moans in the middle of class
and just looks at everybody
and just goes back to doing his work, like.